hi my name is Sean Sharon I'm a software
engineer with Wolfram research today
I'll be talking about two important data
formats in Wolfram language CSV and PDF
updates to them and building high level
applications hello everyone my name is
Shawn chair and I'm a software engineer
at Wolfram research today I'll be
talking about some updates to two very
important formats PDF and CSV and I'll
also show some ways that we can use
these formats to build high level
applications straight out him to say I
had a little technical difficulties just
now
I wasn't expecting my kernel to die when
I plugged in the computer so let's hope
that we can still go through this smooth
so to start we have some changes that
we're making at the important X short
and the volume all right is that a
little better
good so in the next version we have
built some mechanisms into import and
export that provides strong low-level
access for specific formats but give
these formats the mechanism to make them
consistent between formats so coming
right away in 12 we have a lot of
formats already using this stuff CSV TSV
excel fits and then the chemical formats
that we are introducing or modifying and
right now the plan is we have a lot of
old formats that aren't using this stuff
that we're going to continue to optimize
to use these things we also plan to
introduce these with any new formats
that we release that have you know parts
of the file that you could access in
particular for CSV and TSV we have
greatly improved partial access in terms
of supporting spans and any kind of span
whether it's from the end of the file
and in any step in in any direction
these parts also you your CSV data could
also contain headers which you may want
to strip or interpret with your datasets
we improve the processing for this as
well as
the interaction between taking the parts
of files Excel has the exact same
support going on with the addition that
you can also query by sheet because it's
a list of 2d sheets we're also
introducing some metadata elements that
are particularly useful to you so that
you can get the number of sheets or the
size of the sheets without actually
having to import all the data I'm also
proud to say that every single bug that
was reported in 11.3 is fixed for 12 no
no buts
so for CSV and TSV if partial access you
already know that we have always
supported you know ragged data and CSV
has a structure where it doesn't
necessarily have the same number of
columns in every row so if we have this
ragged data right here we can see you
know it increases by one for each row
now any span that you can throw at it is
going to work properly and not only this
but the dimensions that you're asking
for are always going to be honored so in
particular if you ask for something
where it's ragged and the data isn't
there we're going to tell you that you
asked for some data that was outside of
the range but we're still going to give
you exactly the structure and form that
you were looking for for Excel this also
means that and this is brand-new that
you can search either by the index or by
the name of the sheet to grab the sheets
that you're looking for and then we can
say just grab the first three rows and
just a quick example of these brand new
elements we have sheet count and
dimensions which returns you know simple
information about your spreadsheet as
efficiently as possible
so the next part of the talk I want to
give some details on kind of the
underlying way that CSV works and how we
can use this to preserve the contents of
our notebook so that we can get back to
it later so first off let's talk about
what happens with CSV data as you throw
any random expression expression with
different depths so with zero dimension
like just this string hello you can
import this back but you're always gonna
get a table back CSV always assumes that
your data is a table of course you could
take the parts and then get back to your
individual string now because in your
list every single element is considered
a row when you pass a one-dimensional
list to CSV every single element is
interpreted as a row so you have a
column vector basically as your result
now your data might not have a
consistent depth in this case where you
have some elements that aren't wrapped
in their vector but you also have a row
that does have multiple elements CSV
automatically fills in the data so that
you always have something rectangular we
have control over this now if we try to
import it and tell it that we don't want
it to fill these rows we find that we
still get this data well that's because
the data was actually there look in the
second column you actually see that
there is a physical element there it's
just empty you can control this when
you're writing to the data so if we
export with fill rows to false we get
exactly the length that we were looking
for in each row then when you're
importing you can do the same thing and
put them back so whether the data was
there or not you can tell it what you're
looking for for data in two dimensions
that this is the case that you've all
seen for any time standard CSV for
higher order dimensions things get a
little weird now we do have to
understand the limitations to the CSV
format when choosing it as a medium for
our data if we want to preserve that
some of these rows were at no depth but
these other ones had a depth of 1 this
is impossible
looking at the CSV data that we get
resulting there's no way to distinguish
from this first row or the second row so
this isn't the most appropriate use case
for it that said if you go higher than
two dimensions this is possible to be
preserved with just a little bit of work
so this third element here
is another nested list inside of it when
we import this back a simple map of to
expression will interpret this strings
if we look at the import for input form
here this is actually just a string but
we have the textual information to
construct the data by using two
expression and this turns out to be a
very good technique for a wide range of
data so for example sparse array when we
when we see a sparse array object molten
language internally knows the best way
to turn this into usable CSV data but
the result here that we get isn't
something that we can just call to
expression on because we actually
understand and look at the underlying
data and and dump that to the csv file
we need to reintroduce this head of
sparse array but it directly interacts
with the type of data that we exported
so you can still round-trip high-level
objects even though CSV is necessarily a
format that has the mechanisms to
understand what those objects mean
there's a list of these types of
expressions that CSV automatically
recognizes in the scope section of the
CSV documentation if you're interested
in looking at other data types I
recommend you look there now one of
these types that we don't have a
representation for is graph and you
might have a collection of graphs that
you want to preserve and import very
quickly in this case we can actually
just basically get the input form of
presentation of these things and yet
again this is nothing more than mapping
to expression over our data and
automatically interpreting all these
graphs and it was very intentionally
designed such that if you have some
arbitrary expression it should be able
to be reconstructed now in particular
data set is one of those things that has
such a complex structure that we had to
really revamp how we can interact with
it and here's where I start losing my
examples now here's a really complicated
data set this data set now if you're
familiar with data set the only way that
you have headers
whether it be row or column headers is
with the structure of associations or
nested associations now once you have
associations you basically have given in
a column header
once you've nest your associations
you've row headers but it doesn't stop
there you can continue to nest deeper
richer associations within your data
structures and well you might be
wondering if CSV is two-dimensional how
could we possibly get back something at
a depth larger than two well if we just
grab a data set of the data this isn't
particularly useful to us not only do we
have all these quantities that we can't
do anything with but the association's
in here
really aren't very readable now we can
grab the expressions we can try the same
technique that I just showed you just to
expression on the data set but we still
now we have quantities that are
interpreted what happened to these
nested associations well part of this
structure is that the data originally
had headers and in order to completely
restructure it we need to know how to
turn some flat 2d data into something
with a dataset that already has the
headers there and this is built directly
into CSV the data set support in CSV is
very rich and very powerful it can
handle any wide range of ragged data
that you can throw at it whether or not
the headers even exists and even though
these are keys of an association it will
construct the most meaningful missing
representation for you so in this case
we have a complicated nested data set
structure and as you can see down here
this is completely equivalent when I
import it back using header lines to
automatically interpret the data set
headers so now let's talk a little bit
about upcoming updates to PDF we've
noticed that the PDF support that we
have in the past is not as strong as we
want it to be and we have been working
very hard to give it a complete overhaul
I can't say that this is coming in the
next version but we have a lot of
progress and it'll be coming very soon
in future versions we plan to add full
support for PDF 2.0 as well as low-level
raster
and image concepts we also will
introduce efficient partial access
similar to CSV in Excel this is
something that we plan to actively
maintain this isn't something that we're
going to write put in the product and
leave we're going to continue to add new
features and make PDF support even more
rich but we are also going to maintain
new versions of PDF as they come out so
if you look at 11.3 here's a PDF 2.0
file with all of these characters that
it just doesn't know how to represent
the constructs for and I heck I can show
you one test that we have in a prototype
version where all of these things are
profit properly interpreted as their
contents so its will not be in twelve
but very likely the next version after I
can't say for sure so now we have CSV
and PDF data and we know that there are
some low-level constructs that we can
use to access parts of these data how do
we build an application where we can
actually use the data that we're getting
and do some important processing so to
start one of the applications for maybe
using partial access and PDF is you
could do some kind of a search you so
here's a PDF that I grabbed from the US
Census Bureau and this is talking about
places with cities that have a
population of greater than 50,000 and
the first few pages will go up to 2012
but I'm really interested in 2017 so
what I can do is to find a very simple
function which goes through and searches
the PDF and actually gives the result of
which pages that finds 2017 now for a
slower operation like pulling in
graphics and such we can only extract
the pages that we need in order to do
our data processing so let's take a look
remember on page one it was just the
intro page and it says something in the
title about 2017 but if we start at page
18 we could say yes this is the data
that has 2017 so
and what I'm trying to show you is part
of the process of actually building the
application these are the kinds of
things that you need to do is take a
quick look and make sure that you have
what you're looking for and it turns out
we do once we're satisfied once we have
the data that we need importing just
that chunk is the most efficient thing
possible so another thing that we could
do with this may be look for particular
data so instead of just looking for the
pages that say 2017 I'm interested to
see something about maybe in the state
of Illinois which page is how many pages
does it show up on that it is a city
with more than 50,000 and here's those
pages but then we could do something
even more interesting do a quick query
to welcome alpha and get the list of all
50 states and all of a sudden we can
very quickly build an association of
pages that contain these data and
something that I found that was
interesting is when you sort these we
see Vermont doesn't have a single city
that has more than 50 thousand people
which was surprising to me and I thought
maybe I did something wrong but as it
turns out we asked well from Alpha again
know the largest city in Vermont is
Burlington with 42,000 people so the
first thing that we're going to need to
do if you want to get some rich
processing and access parts of our PDF
in order to do some analysis is trim
down to the table that we're looking for
so just some very simple image take
functions can get us very close to the
data that we're looking for so here is
just the import we see that there's more
things than we need a simple trim and
now we're looking at just the table
you'll notice I didn't bother to trim
the sides it's very easy to detect the
lines or any kind of grid in here so
this technique that I'm going to show
you has been tested on a number of
applications where there is a table of
data in your PDF and there's some grid
inside of it that you want to access the
parts of so basic text recognition is
quite easy to do and here's where I lost
my dynamics so we're looking at page 3
here and this is a different
now we're just gonna look at the
populations for all the states in the
United States and we can see up here
there's a row with the populations of
the entire country and we can take the
original image and the first thing that
we need to do if we're going to detect
these grid lines is determine exactly
where they are by first finding the
threshold that we need to binarize the
image such that we get solid grid lines
and right as soon as we have solid grid
lines we can take a look at this and get
an idea of the parameter that we used
and actually binarize that image so now
I have my set of images that are
binarized with just a few lines of
Wolfram language code you can go through
and find the peaks of the values and the
rows and columns and it very clearly
points to you exactly where each row and
column starts and we can highlight the
image and see exactly the dot for each
boundary once we know the coordinates
for each boundary segmenting the image
is very simple to do by just making
rectangles of the data and you can see
this list structure already contains the
structure of the data now we just need
to go from these images into something
that's actually usable and computable
this is where we get into text
recognition so we have the segmented
image and this is as simple as text
recognized mapped over this list of
segmented images all of a sudden we have
raw strings here of actual content that
we can work with but we're not quite
there yet because we want to do some
kind of numerical analysis on this data
and this is already very clean in fact
the only thing that I'm seeing right now
that needs to be adjusted is there's
like a space in this one numeric value
and if we look at a grid of that well
maybe not so if we put this all together
this is really all the code that took
this goes from one of the images
grabbing the boundaries segmenting the
image binarized it
and recognizing the contents so with
this combined data that we get we have
everything that we need to start
verifying that we have what we want and
now we have text data from the PDF CSV
isn't a format that can just be used to
save your data import of csv also has
rich processing to interpret and
understand things like headers so we
take our original image here and this is
just a screenshot from the original PDF
you can kind of see the the numbers here
and so we want to make sure that we
actually got the right numbers well the
way that we can do that is by starting
here with exporting the data to CSV
which just gives us strings yeah at this
point we've exported the data to a file
but CSV is just a text file anyway we
still can't do any computational
processes on this when you import CSV
though it has the capabilities to turn
strings into their numeric
representations not only that but in
features that have been recently
released allow you to go directly to the
data set so that you have name fields
so with header lines we already have a
data set that is entirely computable if
we look here this is that first row and
the rest of the columns saying that
these are the totals that were
originally in the data set for the
United States and if we look at these I
know because I had to magnify it you
can't see them together anymore but I
can tell you they were correct and I'll
upload this notebook and you can
definitely verify now not only did we
get that total from you know the line
that we imported that to the United
States but if we actually sum the
populations for each state these are
exactly identical so we can be
reasonably confident that this is
exactly the data that we were looking
for it is already computable at a high
level and we didn't really need to do
any processing all we needed to do was
understand the data from the format of
CSV so the last thing that I want to
mention and I didn't have quite enough
time to put together an example for this
but
some of the concerns with importing CSV
data is well it is just a text file you
can really dump any amount of data to a
CSV file and this can get quite large
pulling all that content into memory
isn't usually in our best interests with
a format like CSV we have to do a little
bit of due diligence in determining what
the best approach for pulling our data
is now here's just a few things to
consider when working with a lot of CSV
data the first thing is that you might
want to buffer your data so that you
only hold so many bytes in memory at one
time while you're doing such processing
the thing that you have to understand
about doing this is that if you're
splitting on lines in order to buffer
your data there might be a new line
within your data where all of a sudden
your buffer stops in the middle of a row
and you've destroyed your data so before
employing one of these techniques what
you should do is make sure that your
data is free from these new lines not
only this but if your data contains many
many columns but very few rows this same
technique of buffering by grabbing each
line isn't going to be very effective
one other thing and this could be you
know a fairly general rule you have to
understand that the the bytes that are
on your computer don't necessarily
immediately um it's not immediately
obvious necessarily which characters
they intended to represent because there
are different encodings for such
characters in fact if you have unicode
values the most likely encoding that
you're going to run into is utf-8 and
now each character isn't even
represented to by only one byte by using
a character encoding of I so latin-1
in any text application you might find
that you get a wonderful performance
increase just because this can be
interpreted directly as the byte stream
so as you can see there are a lot of
tools that you can use to quickly and
with high-performance Access CSV data
and work between bat and PDF thank you
you